hey guys Mary here and I'm gonna talk to
you about rise of the Tomb Raider the
second game in the three-part series
from developer Crystal Dynamics I got to
play the game for three hours and I'm
gonna break down everything new from the
first game as well as anything else I
found interesting first up are the stats
and skill points in the original game
you had survivor and hunter skills they
were skills all in a row that you
unlocked as you completed them in this
game you have three brawler hunter and
survivor brawler is hand-to-hand combat
in healing so in this one there's
multiple tiers of skills that get
unlocked as you master the skills some
of the skills can work together such as
thick skinned and heart of stones so
that you can take less damage in the
hunters here it helps with hunting and
scavenging these are gonna feel really
familiar these are ones like recovering
arrows or looting more off of corpses or
moving faster finally you have survivor
crafting and exploration abilities these
help you craft faster and on the run you
can craft while you're in the world now
you don't have to be at a bonfire so
it's be really helpful for times when
you need to heal so you can hide in
combat craft an item and then use it to
heal yourself while you're still
fighting this is also where you'll boost
physical stats like taking less damage
when we fall from height there's a lot
more customization in the skills now and
where I found in the first game as soon
as I had a point to spend there was only
like a few places to put it
now there's countless items so you're
able to customize your lara much more to
your own individual play style so if you
don't want to be in combat a lot you
want to be more of a stealthy player
you're gonna put more points into the
hunter and survivor whereas if you're
fighting a lot you're probably gonna put
a lot of those points into brawler which
will help you stay alive next up are
your weapon options and upgrades as with
the first game you're gonna start with
your climbing axe but you very quickly
get your bow and as far as I got you
could also change into two outfits you
get one for expedition and one for
raiding tombs and yes you can wear your
tank top in the snow if you want to
you'll find ammo parts in the world just
like in the first game so I'm currently
searching for two more semi-auto pistol
parts once you find all the parts or you
just stumble across an entire weapon
like
revolver you can upgrade it this is also
a tiered system similar to skill points
that you can unlock for more
customization upgrades are similar to
the last game things like stability or
more damage and they're in exchange for
resources that you find in the world
cloth animal skins feathers and in
various parts these items especially in
the beginning of the game like your bow
require a lot of materials so you'll
want to be constantly hunting so that
you have everything you need when you're
ready to upgrade finally there's an
inventory section that will help you
upgrade your ammunition and equipment
equipment upgrades are things you might
remember like holding more arrows or
more shotgun shells it's incredibly
helpful but a lot of these materials are
the same materials used for upgrading
your weapons so a lot of times you'll
have to choose between your weapon doing
more damage or Lara's ability to hold
more bullets in the ammunition upgrades
those are things like hollow-point
bullets or stealthy arrows for
additional damage in control they are
also unlocked in exchange for resources
when it comes to the world there are
some changes to crafting in combat as I
mentioned before you can craft on the
fly now you don't have to be at a
bonfire so as long as you've learned the
skill and you have the materials for
example poison mushrooms for a poison
arrow the game will prompt you to craft
wherever you are something new that I've
never seen in the game before is a
shopkeeper it gives you tools and gear
in exchange for gold coins that you find
scattered throughout the area so it's a
little bit more motivation for you to
scavenge the area for twos and hidden
caves there's items in there that you
might find familiar like the Rope
ascender and he'll also offer tools
which will unlock new tiers of weapon
upgrades in your skill tree so it sounds
like it will actually require gold for
you to be able to get certain weapon
upgrades when it comes to combat there's
some additional player choice involved
you can choose between being still
see or just being a fighter some areas
require you to fight and others you can
get by without killing anyone you'll
know which ones they are because they
basically are guaranteeing you at some
point you're gonna be down a corridor
and there's a dude there who's going to
find you but even in these areas that
require you to fight there's lots of
bushes that you can stay hidden in and
you can shoot arrows for silent
takedowns you get xp for stealth kills
so it's best to try and be sneaky as
opposed to just going in guns blazing
there's also more opportunity for world
items like lanterns that you can use to
your advantage you can use them in
combat or they'll just help you get to
another area the Soviet encampment area
is the most open world I've ever seen in
a Tomb Raider game there's so much to
discover and you can do a lot of it in
any order you like depending on what's
interesting to you if you pause the game
there's a region summary that shows
everything that you can find from hidden
tombs to relics to coin caches that you
can spend at the shop there are new
optional missions in the game these are
side quests and they help you make
allies that will give you rewards for
example this one will give you a
lockpick you don't have to do them but
it looks like these dudes might come
back to help you later on so it seems
like it's in your best interest to do
them there's also new challenges that
give you additional XP these are things
like exploring dark caves and these are
not the same as tombs yes optional tombs
are back there seems to be a lot more of
them and they reward you with treasures
and relics you'll be able to know when
you're in the area of one it will prompt
you and say that there's an optional
tomb nearby you can find documents which
help fill in additional pieces of the
story including what your allies are
doing there you can also find murals and
this helps Laura learn languages if she
reads about like five or so pieces she
becomes familiar with the language and
then you can go back and cover more
secrets from pieces you couldn't read
before you can also find relics again
and just like before you're rewarded for
turning them around and zooming in and
checking them out in more details
and you'll uncover a little bit more
about that item you also find a range of
strong boxes and survival packs that
will reward you with inventory items for
additional crafting so you can go
through all these caves and optional
tombs at any point you want but if you
want to go back to the main mission you
can press in the right stick it will
highlight the next checkpoint which will
in turn progress the story you'll always
be able to return later to this area via
fast travel if you miss something so
that's most of what I learned from three
hours I got to play every time I see
this game I get more and more excited
they basically took what I loved about
the first Tomb Raider and then just
double down on it there's way more
customization from Laura's skills to how
you fight see what you explore all
within an area that's way way bigger
than anything we've seen in the first
game I'll continue to update you guys
with anything else tomb raider related
so stay tuned